is one of only a few Palestinian
Bedouins left in the maharajat area in
the occupied West Bank
their lifestyle depends on herding
livestock but it's now under threat
over the last several years Israeli
settlers have begun establishing herding
and farming outposts firmly hat that
means half of the lands available for
grazing are now off limits Palestinian
Shepherds say settlers often attack them
and their flocks they want us out of
these lands they don't want any better
one here if someone protects me in my
livestock we won't leave will be
reassured if peace activists come to
help us to expose Israel those settlers
are crazy people on the loose this is an
Israeli policy
some of those who attack his family come
from settlement outposts like this one
it's been expanding into more
Palestinian lands since it was
established in 2004
Palestinians say they've gotten used to
the cycle the more violent settlers
exercise the faster they get pushed off
of their lands all these settlements
together they are supposed to close
Jericho so Jericho won't Expendable knot
Drew atkis has been monitoring
settlement expansion for more than two
decades
his research shows how those outposts
are used to take more Palestinian lands
he says the way they spread out is not
random 77 settler farming outposts have
been established in the occupied West
Bank
66 of them during the last decade
although they're not recognized by the
Israeli government they receive funds
and services from governmental bodies
grazing has played an important role in
determining their location
says farming outposts are used to
control Palestinian lands that build up
settlements cannot most of these are
settlers which are dwelling in these
hours they belong to the most extreme
and most violent sector within the
Israeli settlements in order to
establish such an outpost you need to be
willing to use a lot of to exercise a
lot of violent
Palestinian Palestinian herders are not
going to live their land unless they are
threatened
40 families are now in this area that's
down from 75 just over a decade ago many
were forced to give up the Bedouin
lifestyle altogether
those who remain fear it's only a matter
of time
Ibrahim Al Jazeera the occupied West
Bank